Jin do you have three books you've
written yeah 3 okay yeah which chapter
of any of those three you get the most
comments on like this has helped me so
much and why well it's interesting I
would say it's the fascinating thing
about TV writing tool kit and that's my
self-published book so that's my only
self-published broken its Jesse doumitt
the writer store encouraged me to put
like five of my work books together in a
book and that's what I did so that's TV
reading toolkit and I would say the the
on that book the comment that I get the
most about is people loving how I break
down the TV shows to show them how my
story system applies to the show because
that helps really cement the idea of how
to use the system in their scripts then
in storyline finding gold in your life
story I would say the chapter I would
say just the theme throughout the book
of adding fiction to your truth in the
recognition that you can use your
emotional truth and hide it so that
people don't know that it happened to
you or it's your story and I would say
that the advantage of storyline finding
gold in your life story is really
helping the writer who wants to move
away from the autobiographical but still
wants to use their emotional truth in a
way that will elevate the writing to a
whole new level and then in change your
story change your life I would say the
biggest comment that I get night I
wouldn't say people come up to me and
say oh this chapter resonated with me
the most i would say they'll say things
like oh
my gosh like you go so deep into your
story and you have so much courage that
it makes me not feel afraid to reveal
and and for me that is key like the
compliment you know starting with TV
writing toolkit which was my first one
you know which is really just the basics
of all the story events and how you
apply story to scripts then moving into
storyline finding gold in your life
story adding fiction to your truth so
got more specific in the intent and then
it applied to features and TV and then
moving into change your story change
your life which is moving toward the
entrepreneur the solopreneur as well as
the writer in the motivational aspect of
how knowing how to tell and sell your
story can serve your outcome in a very
strong way and how you can take a
negative turn and become the hero in
your own story and create the type of
life you want to be living
you